Awesome. So now Box2D is created and can be updated each frame. Our next step
is to add physics body to the world, so that we can simulate them properly. To
create a physics object, we have to jump through a few hoop. The first thing we
need to do is actually create a BodyDef object. Now Body Definition object is
going to be used later to actually create our body. But what we do in here is
that we actually set some specific properties on it. For example, whether or
not its dynamic or static. Think of static objects as the ones that will never
move in your environment. Walls, trees, stone chickens, things like that.
Dynamic bodies are the ones that move and can react to physics. Once you've set
your properties for your body definition, you need then to call
world.CreateBody. This will actually tell Box2D to create a, Physics object
based on the definitions that you just passed into it. And of course, it will
return a handle to this object, so that you can use it too. Once your object
has actually been created, the next thing you need to do is actually set the
physics properties on the object. Box2D does this using what they would call a
Fixture Definition. Now fixture definition defines properties that allow you to
set the density, friction, restitution, mass, things along these lines.
Basically how this object is going to interact with the physics of the world
around it. Generally in a game, you'll have groups of objects that all resemble
the same similar physical characteristics. As such, you may want to go through
and actually group them into certain types of fixtures. For Grits/g, we
actually have the majority of objects in the world use a specific fixture
object that react to the world in the same way. However, we have one type of
bullet that can be launched from the bouncy bullet gun, that actually uses a
different fixture. As such, we allow the entity Def object, passed in from the
user, to actually have a flag defining whether of not this is a BouncyFixture
object. From there we can actually set the density and friction differently, so
that it hits the wall and contains its velocity moving forward. As you write
your game application, it's probably worth while to take into account. How all
things should react in the environment and use different fixtures
appropriately. Now, once you've defined the fixture information about how the
world should react with the object, we actually need to define the shape of the
object. The shape is the most critical, as it defines how this object should
interact with the rest of the world. Now, Box2D has support for polygons,
circles and oddly enough, boxes, right, who'd the thunk/g? Now it's worth
pointing out, that most physics engines support a suite of whole definitions.
But give huge performance winds to simplistic wholes like spheres, circles,
boxes and cubes. Polygons are always an option, but expect to pay a performance
penalty for the flexibility you're gaining. The fixture definition supports a
suite of these API's. Such as the SetAsBox method, which of course will define
the fixture definition as a box. Once you've got all these parameters set, you
call the CreateFixture method on side of the Body Definition that's been given
to you. And this will effectively attach the shape and information, to the body
definition. From there, you're pretty much done. You've got a physics object
that'll react to the world and do all the things you tell it to do. So go ahead
and return it out to the calling function.